[Musik]
Dieser Podcast wird Ihnen von der LMU
München präsentiert. Vielen Dank, vielen
Dank, Mina und Yun, für diesen herzlichen
Empfang und die Einladung und dafür,
dass ich Ihnen allen für Ihr
Kommen danke  Bilder von
globaler Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit und was
ich versuchen werde, ist heute Abend
zusammen mit Ihnen zu verstehen, wann unsere internationalen
gesundheitlichen Ungleichheiten ungerecht sind oder
als Angelegenheiten globaler Gerechtigkeit betrachtet werden
sollten und eher als Probleme der Gerechtigkeit
als als Probleme einer anderen
Moral betrachtet werden sollten  Sorge und wenn wir haben, was
Gerechtigkeit erfordert, wer wie und
warum aus welchem Grund handeln soll, und schnell meine
Karten auf den Tisch legen, falls jeman
aus dem Gespräch herauszoomt, denke ich, dass einige gesun
heitliche Ungleichheiten Angelegenheiten der globa
en Gerechtigkeit sind, aber nicht alle  von ihnen sind einige
von ihnen Angelegenheiten der innerstaatlichen Justiz
und einige von ihnen sind Angelegenheiten von
humanitärem Interesse, und dies ist nicht
sehr überraschend, dass die meisten philosophischen
Berichte einen Plural haben  istische moralische
Erwägungen in Bezug auf die globale
Gesundheit und Entbehrungen im Gesundheitswesen Ich
denke jedoch, dass es einen größeren
Spielraum für Gerechtigkeit in der globalen Gesundheit gibt, als
wir derzeit anerkennen, und wir
können mehr gesundheitliche Beeinträchtigungen unter
das Banner der Gerechtigkeit fassen, als allgemein
angenommen wird, und ich werde es versuchen  Ich zeige Ihnen dies,
indem ich neben der Erörterung zweier prominenter
Ansichten in der Literatur versuche,
einige Überlegungen zur Entwicklung einer, wie
ich sie nenne, globalen, relationalen, egalitären
Darstellung von Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit anzustellen, und hofft
, eine neuartige Antwort auf die
Frage zu geben, was einige gesundheitliche
Ungleichheiten zu globalen Themen macht  Gerechtigkeit
, warum also spreche ich
zur Enttäuschung einiger von
Ihnen über Bilder der Gerechtigkeit? Wahrscheinlich werde ich Ihnen
heute Abend keine schönen Bilder zeigen, vielleicht sollte ich,
aber der Titel bezieht sich auf einen
verstärkten Aufsatz mit dem Titel „Zwei Bilder der
Gerechtigkeit“, und er entlehnt den Begriff „Bilder
der Gerechtigkeit“.  von Vidkun
Stein schreibt er erzwungene Rechte, dass ein Bild
unsere Sprache
über einen Cer prägt  Bei einem Thema bringt es
die verschiedenen Verwendungen eines Wortes zusammen und bildet
so seine Grammatik, so
verstehen und verwenden wir ein Wort, aber solche
Bilder können unser
Verständnis von etwas auch in die falsche Richtung lenken,
ähnlich wie beim Betrachten des berühmten
Vexierbildes einer Ente  und Kaninchen
kann man nur einen Aspekt auf einmal sehen oder da
unser Denken von bestimmten Beispielen bestimmt wird
, die uns zu falschen
Verallgemeinerungen führen, so drückt ein Bild von
Gerechtigkeit eine allgemeine und dicke
Denkweise über Gerechtigkeit und Ungerechtigkeit aus, also im
Grunde, was Kraft versucht
Hier geht es darum, darüber nachzudenken, wie unsere
Vorstellungen von Gerechtigkeit in einem normativen Sinne strukturiert sind,
und sie eröffnen sowohl
Denkweisen über Gerechtigkeit auf eine
bestimmte Weise, schließen sie aber auch auf
andere Weise, und daher zeichne ich hier im
Grunde  eine normative Struktur
für derzeit bestehende Darstellungen
globaler Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit aufzustellen, und ich betrachte im
Wesentlichen fünf Grundelemente der
normativen Struktur und
möchte t verwenden  seine fünfdimensionale normative
Struktur, um darüber nachzudenken, was
an diesen Konzepten der globalen Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit positiv und willkommen ist,
und
vielleicht, was wir überdenken und
auf das hinarbeiten sollten, was ich diese relationale wie
eine latarische Darstellung nenne, also das erste Element
, über das ich sprechen werde  ist die Rolle
oder das Wesen der Gesundheit in einer Theorie der
Gerechtigkeit, und hier stellt sich normalerweise die Frage,
ob Gesundheit etwas
Besonderes ist und die Verteilung der Gesundheit
von anderen Aspekten des
persönlichen oder sozialen Lebens einer Person isoliert werden kann oder wie
manche denken, ein Teil davon ist  die oder die
grundlage des menschlichen wohlergehens oder menschlichen
gedeihens oder vielleicht auch
anders gesundheit ist grundsätzlich
konstitutiver teil unseres lebensprospekts
autonome akteure oder gesamtvorteile
in jedem fall muss eine globale bilanz von gesundheitsgerechtigkeit
entscheiden, wie über
die rolle und die zu denken ist  Natur der Gesundheit in einem
globalen Kontext und ob dieser globale
Aspekt uns veranlasst, die Natur und die Rolle
der Heilung zu überdenken  In einer Theorie der Gerechtigkeit betrifft das
zweite Element dieser normativen
Struktur die Ursprünge von Krankheitsrechten,
so dass wir typischerweise
über den Ursprung von Gesundheit als
natürliche, natürlich vorkommende, natürliche
Ursachen von Krankheit, soziale oder sozial
bedingte Gesundheitsverschlechterungen
nachdenken, und wir denken auch  über unsere persönliche
Verantwortung bei der Herbeiführung bestimmter
Krankheiten und die Frage für eine
normative Theorie ist, ob die
unterschiedliche Behandlung der Ursachen von
Gesundheitsdeprivation moralisch gerechtfertigt ist
oder nicht, also das ist sozusagen der zweite
Aspekt der dritte Aspekt oder Element
einer Vorstellung hier  ist der Grund der
Gerechtigkeit, warum wir verpflichtet sind,
gesundheitliche Beeinträchtigungen zu beheben, und
dies wird eine
besonders schwierige Aufgabe im
globalen Bereich sein, in dem eine Art
Gerechtigkeit besteht oder unsere Gerechtigkeitspflichten
nicht so streng in unsere globalen eingebettet sind
Beziehungen der Solidarität und
Gleichberechtigung das vierte Element ist das, was ich
nenne und zu dem ich gekommen bin  in der
Literatur als der Ort der Gerechtigkeit bekannt sein, und
dieser Aspekt bezieht sich auf
die Art von Dingen, auf die
ein Gerechtigkeitsprinzip angewendet wird, was
wir mit Begriffen von Gerechtigkeit und Ungerechtigkeit bewerten,
was für Dinge sein sollten
untersucht und wieder gibt
es viele Möglichkeiten, wir betrachten
die Verteilung von Gesundheit in der Gesellschaft oder
im globalen Bereich die Verteilung der
Lebenserwartung zum Beispiel,
betrachten wir Handlungen, die Menschen anderen antun,
oder vielleicht institutionell vermittelte
Handlungen und wie wir unsere gestalten  gemeinsame
Institutionen und welche Wirkung sie
auf die Menschen haben, also gibt es hier wieder mehrere
Möglichkeiten und schließlich ist das fünfte
Element das Gerechtigkeitsprinzip, was
Gerechtigkeit hier erfordert und ob
die moralische Sorge mit absoluter
Gesundheitsentbehrung oder relativer
gesundheitlicher Ungleichheit einhergeht und was ist
zwei Personen ist ein minimaler oder
anständiger Gesundheitszustand oder dass wir
die Lücke
entlang eines ganzen Spektrums schließen  gesundheitliche
Ungleichheit, das sind also die
fünf Elemente, die Rolle, die Ursachen von
Krankheit, der Grund der Gerechtigkeit, der Ort der
Gerechtigkeit und das Prinzip der Gerechtigkeit, und
ich denke, dass sie der Unterschied zu
sehr tiefen philosophischen Kontroversen
über das Wesen und den Zweck des
Theoretisierens sind  über Gerechtigkeit und wie sie
auf den speziellen Bereich der
Gesundheit zutrifft, was ich also in der
Art des konstruktiven
Teils des Papiers argumentieren werde, ist, dass ich argumentiere, dass ein Kern einer
plausiblen und noch unerforschten
Konzeption globaler Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit der ist  Idee der
Gleichberechtigung in globalen Angelegenheiten oder
Gleichberechtigung in einer globalen politischen
Gemeinschaft Globale Gerechtigkeit erfordert, dass
wir
in unseren globalen Angelegenheiten gleichberechtigte Beziehungen
aufbauen und im Laufe der Zeit
Verteilungsfragen in Bezug auf
wertvolle Kodizes wie Gesundheit vor Erosion schützen, die nicht
von alleine entstehen  Begriffe entstehen aus meiner Sicht aber
in Bezug auf dieses besondere
Ideal Gesundheit bzw. Gesundsein ist
konstitutiv o  f Ein Instrument
für gleichberechtigte Beziehungen in globalen
Angelegenheiten ist die Frage nach globaler
Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit also unser Gesundheitszustand
, seine Ursachen und die Art und Weise, wie er
unsere Fähigkeit beeinflusst, als gleichberechtigtes
Mitglied dieser globalen Gemeinschaft zu stehen, welche Art von
Entbehrungen im Gesundheitswesen entstehen
Gerechtigkeitsansprüche und nicht
plausible Gerechtigkeitsansprüche lassen
sich aus dem ableiten, was wir uns
in einer globalen Gemeinschaft von Gleichberechtigten an
Schutz und Förderung
der Gesundheit des anderen schuldig sind, mit Verweis auf die
engagierte philosophische Debatte über den
Wert der Gleichheit  Ich nenne diese Position einen
relationalen Aquila-Tirion-Bericht über
globale Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit, und ich werde zu dem
Schluss kommen, dass gesundheitliche Ungleichheiten
Angelegenheiten globaler Gerechtigkeit sind, wenn sie
aus einer unfairen Vereinbarung der
globalen politischen Determinanten von Gesundheit resultieren,
wobei globale Vereinbarungen die globalen
Vereinbarungen zunächst fair sind  sie
haben eine faire Auswirkung auf die globale Gesundheit,
zweitens mildern sie die Auswirkungen der sozialen
Abschreckung  abgebaute Krankheit aufgrund des
gleichen Respekts und sie mildern auch die
Auswirkungen der natürlichen Gesundheit Deborah
auf der Basis des gleichen respektvollen Menschen,
also werden dies jetzt die drei
Anforderungen sein, natürlich besonders
für diejenigen unter Ihnen, die keine
Philosophen im Raum sind, es ist wichtig
Um zu sehen, was auf dem Spiel steht, wenn
wir für ein bestimmtes Verständnis von
Gerechtigkeit in der globalen Gesundheit
eintreten, ist es meiner Meinung nach wichtig, zunächst
die Stärken und die Idee zu klären, die
Sie lehren, um bestimmte gesundheitliche Deprivationen anzugehen, die
weltweite
Gerechtigkeitspflichten und nicht nur Probleme sind
humanitäre Sorge oder Nächstenliebe,
außerdem werden sich unterschiedliche Vorstellungen von
Gerechtigkeit darüber streiten, was
wir einander in Bezug auf Gesundheit schulden und warum
es wahrscheinlich ist, dass sich plausible
Vorstellungen überschneiden, beispielsweise in ihren
Forderungen, extreme
Depressionen weltweit auszurotten, so dass wir eine
Vielzahl moralischer Gründe haben
diese ungeheuerlichsten gesundheitsbedingten
Schäden und Ungerechtigkeiten anzusprechen, und das ist meines Erachtens eine
willkommene Angelegenheit  Als Folge unserer moralischen
Argumentation hat die normative Grammatik
der globalen Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit jedoch wichtige
Auswirkungen auf die Art der Maßnahmen und
Richtlinien, die sie fordert, sowie auf die Art und
das Ausmaß unserer globalen Anwendungen
und angesichts des Ausmaßes der
globalen Krankheitslast und der begrenzten
Ressourcen, die wir haben  Die
normative Theorie muss sich damit befassen und klare
Leitlinien für die Festlegung von Prioritäten für
globale Gesundheitsmaßnahmen bereitstellen. Ich denke, dies
sind einige der Gründe, warum es
sinnvoll ist, diese Dinge auf
philosophischer Ebene zu diskutieren und zu einigen
Schlussfolgerungen zu kommen und hoffentlich zu einigen normativen
Verschiebung in unserem Verständnis Okay,
beginnend mit dem ersten Bild der
globalen Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit könnte
es einigen von Ihnen bekannt sein, also
werde ich im Grunde zwei Bilder ansprechen,
bevor ich mit der Entwicklung
des dritten fortfahre, das ich vorhabe  Um zuerst
über den Ansatz der Gesundheitsfähigkeit zu sprechen, wie
er von Sridhar Venkatapuram entwickelt wurde,
werde ich mich dann mit COS von
Beziehungen befassen  Ursache des Beziehungismus am
prominentesten in Thomas Pacus Darstellung der
globalen Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit, und schließlich versuche ich
, meine Sicht auf diesen relationalen
wie einen latarischen Ansatz zu begründen
Fähigkeiten-
Ansatz, der von Amartya Sen und
Martha Nussbaum
für den Fall der Gesundheit entwickelt wurde. Eine Möglichkeit,
über das Problem nachzudenken, besteht darin, zu untersuchen,
was die Fähigkeit, gesund zu sein, mit sich
bringt und welche Art von Ansprüchen und
Verpflichtungen daraus erwachsen, wie Sridhar
Venkatapuram es in seinem Buch 2011 tut  Wie
versteht Venkatapuram die Rolle in der
Natur der Gesundheit im Allgemeinen? Der
Fähigkeitsansatz schätzt Gesundheit sowohl
intrinsisch als auch instrumentell
von diesem
orthodoxen Gesundheitsverständnis innerhalb der
Leistungsfähigkeit ca  ach und vertritt eine breite
Sichtweise von Gesundheit, die wertvolles
Tun und Sein für ein würdevolles menschliches
Leben umfasst, da er sagt, gesund zu sein
, ist seiner Ansicht nach eine Metafähigkeit, einschließlich
anderer grundlegender Fähigkeiten, entwickelt er eine
positive Vorstellung von Gesundheit im Gegensatz
zur Standardansicht der Abwesenheit von Krankheit  und
argumentiert, dass Proteingesundheit als
ein Cluster von grundlegenden Fähigkeiten und Codes betrachtet werden sollte,
welche Fähigkeiten enthalten sein sollen
und aus welchen Gründen Ideen, die er
aus NAS Baums Version des
Fähigkeitenansatzes entlehnt, so dass die Fähigkeit
, gesund zu sein, die zehn
zentralen menschlichen Fähigkeiten umfasst  die
nospam auf ihrer Liste hat und Personen Anspruch
auf ein ausreichendes Maß von allem haben, was
für ein würdevolles menschliches Leben notwendig ist, also ist im Grunde
der Anspruch, den Personen auf
diese Fähigkeit haben, gesund zu sein, weil
sie sich im Grunde aus Jo-Anns
Familie und Sichtweise ergibt, in Nr  erstreckt sich über die
Vorstellung von Menschenwürde, also ist hier die
Art der Rolle und das Wesen der
Gesundheit auf der ersten Seite  Bild der
Gerechtigkeit Was ist mit den Ursprüngen von Krankheit
Venkatapuram sue steht auf einem weiteren
wichtigen Pfeiler, der seine Darstellung
der globalen Gesundheit gerecht
macht, was ich als hybride Fähigkeitssicht bezeichne.
Die sozialen Determinanten von Gesundheit
spielen in seiner Theorie eine entscheidende Rolle. Zuerst haben
diese sozialen Determinanten  Eine
besonders relevante kausale Rolle bei der
Erklärung von vermeidbaren Beeinträchtigungen
und vorzeitigem Tod, die
den Gesundheitszustand einer Person im Zusammenspiel
mit anderen Faktoren mitbestimmen. Dies sind die Faktoren
, die die biologische Uhr verursachen. Individuelles
Verhalten und die äußere physische
Umgebung  soziale Determinanten haben,
aber was noch wichtiger ist, soziale
Determinanten wirken auch als Ursachen von Ursachen, da das
Aussehen der Katze sie beeinflusst und
möglicherweise die biologischen
Auswirkungen auf das Verhalten und die Umwelt auf die
Gesundheit verstärkt. Diese empirische Rolle der sozialen
Determinanten der Gesundheit ist entscheidend,
weil sie möglicherweise die liefern wird
wichtigsten Ort des öffentlichen Handelns
und seine Reichweite erheblich erweitern,
wann immer ein Eingreifen möglich ist, ist es
eine Forderung der Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit,
die sozialen Ursachen zu beseitigen, die
die Ausübung der Fähigkeit einer Person
, gesund zu sein, einschränken, und dann ein Params zu streichen Worte, die
jeder Mensch eine Moral hat
anspruch auf die gesellschaftliche basis einer
gerechten gesundheitsfähigkeit und
zitiere sicher sein
gerechtigkeitsprinzip das dritte element in der auffassung
das verteilungsprinzip ist
meiner meinung nach ein hybrides prinzip, das
einerseits ein bestimmtes
verteilungsprinzip und ein ergebnis hat  Muster
in Bezug auf die relevante Metrik,
die die ausreichende
Gesundheit für alle ist, im Hinterkopf, andererseits wird
dieses Ergebnis in seinem Bild
auf prozedurale Weise erreicht, es ist nicht nur ein
Standard, um Muster oder
Verteilungen von Gesundheit zu bewerten, sondern es
sagt uns auch  etwas darüber, wie dies
zustande kommen sollte, also wird es auf
prozedurale Weise erreicht, indem die soziale
Basis der Heilung neu angeordnet wird  Daher wird die richtige
Anordnung der sozialen Basis
durch die Linse eines bestimmten
Ergebnisses im Auge bewertet, das den
Bewertungsmaßstab für ihre
Neuordnung liefert,
wenn wir Elizabeth Andersons
Kategorien von Verteilungsregeln hier
im Spiel für diejenigen Philosophen anwenden wollen, die
besonders sind  interessiert sich für Theorien der
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit. Seine Ansicht ist eine
mustersensible Beschränkungs-Prozedurregel.
Sie erfordert, dass alle ein
ausreichendes Maß an Gelegenheit haben,
gesund zu sein, wenn sich diese Gelegenheit
aus bestimmten Arten der sozialen Organisation ergibt.
Was also das vierte Element ist, ist der Anblick
von Gerechtigkeit für Venkatapuram  Wie ich bereits sagte,
hat er ein ideales Verteilungsmuster im
Sinn, das wir durch unsere
Vorstellungen von Gerechtigkeit in Bezug auf diese gewählte
Metrik der Gesundheitsfähigkeit einschränken sollten.
Der Anspruch einer Person bezieht sich jedoch nicht auf ein Niveau
der Gesundheitsfähigkeit an sich, sondern auf ihre
soziale Grundlage für eine Gesellschaft  Um nur
die soziale Basis zu sein, müsste sie so
organisiert sein, dass sie zusammenpassen
Äther ein ausreichendes Maß an gesundheitlicher
Leistungsfähigkeit, das für ein würdiges Leben erforderlich ist,
endlich auf die Gründe der Gerechtigkeit zu bringen,
und hier werde ich auch ein paar
Fragen oder Bedenken
äußern, wenn Kattappa sein
Konto erden lässt. Tut mir leid, wenn Cata Purim ihm
sein Konto gewährt  Die Idee der Menschenwürde
und dies nach ihm
bietet sich automatisch für einen globalen Geltungsbereich
der Gerechtigkeit an Alle Personen haben grundsätzlich Ansprüche auf
Fähigkeiten vorpolitischer
Natur Personen haben diese Ansprüche
vor und unabhängig von der Zugehörigkeit zu einer
bestimmten politischen Gemeinschaft, sobald
diese universell sind  Ansprüche werden anerkannt,
die Handlungen von Individuen und sozialen
Strukturen von der lokalen bis zur globalen
können in Bezug auf die Fähigkeiten als gut oder schlecht beurteilt werden
, während
nicht ganz klar ist, was damit gemeint
ist, in Bezug auf etwas beurteilt zu werden, von dem ich
annehme, dass Venkatapuram  stellt sich die
Idee der globalen Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit
folgendermaßen vor Ich denke, dass seiner Meinung
nach alle pro  Söhne haben berechtigte Ansprüche auf
die für ein
menschenwürdiges Leben notwendigen Grundfähigkeiten und es ist die
Pflicht aller anderen, die Menschlichkeit in
den Anspruchsberechtigten anzuerkennen, dafür zu sorgen, dass ihr
Handeln und die diese Fähigkeiten wirkenden mehrstufigen gesellschaftlichen und
globalen Strukturen
schon
jetzt auf die Zielerreichung hinarbeiten  Um ein
paar Probleme mit dem Venkatapuram-
Ansatz zur Gesundheitsfähigkeit anzusprechen. Ich denke, dass das
Problem hier mindestens zweifach ist, und
wir haben dieses Argument in einer Ausgabe
von Bioethics 2016 mit zwei meiner Kollegen
aus Munster, Elena Peaks und Sebastian
Lau, vorgebracht, also haben wir '  Ich habe argumentiert, dass
der Anspruch der Menschen auf die Fähigkeit
, gesund zu sein, zunächst aus der Idee
der Menschenwürde abgeleitet wird, so dass die Menschen den
Grund, warum Menschen gültige Ansprüche haben
, auf ihrer Eigenschaft als Menschen
und dem Grund, warum andere verpflichtet sind
, ihnen dabei zu helfen, basieren  Das Erreichen eines
Schwellenwerts in ihrer
Gesundheit ist groß, weil sie
diese Menschlichkeit in der Klägerin
erkennen  Sollte dies keine Darstellung der
eigentlichen Gerechtigkeit sein, sondern Ansprüche auf Gerechtigkeit
basieren auf Menschlichkeit, so wird dies
im Grunde ein Prinzip der Menschlichkeit sein, und
ich werde gleich erklären, warum
dies für unsere Zwecke problematisch sein könnte, und ich
denke, das zweite  Problem, das ich
jetzt nur erwähnen und nicht
zu lange ausklammern werde, gibt es eine Zweideutigkeit hinsichtlich
seines Gerichtsstandorts zwischen
sozial verursachten
Hausverderbnissen und solchen, die sozial
kontrollierbar oder sozial behebbar sind, und
beide Elemente haben wichtige
normative Implikationen für rein
natürliche Gesundheitsschäden
, warum denken wir also, dass es problematisch ist, die
globale Gesundheitspflicht auf ein Konto der
Menschheit zu begründen,
was ist die moralische Grundlage unserer Pflicht,
Gesundheitsdefizite weltweit zu lindern
, das ist sozusagen die Frage, die wir
zu beantworten und zu nutzen versuchen  Der Begriff
ungerecht und ungerecht und im
Grunde der wertende Begriff Vertrauen zu verwenden ist sehr
weit gefasst und verurteilt jede Form des
Menschen  Entbehrung unabhängig von ihrer
Art oder Region und der zugrunde liegenden
Begründung, sie anzugehen, ist problematisch,
wie Brian Barry anmerkte, dass dies zu einer
Abstumpfung unseres moralischen
Vokabulars und damit zu einem Verlust an
Präzision in unserem moralischen Denken führen kann,
von dem Barry dagegen ein
Prinzip unterscheidet  Humanität, die auf Coldplay
basiert, um
Leiden oder fortgeschrittenes Wohlergehen zu lindern, von einem auf
Rechten basierenden Gerechtigkeitsprinzip,
das darauf abzielt,
legitime Ansprüche zu regeln, haben sie sehr
unterschiedliche Begründungen und sehr unterschiedliche
Auswirkungen auf die Praxis und aus
der Sicht von Rams  gesundheitsbezogene Angaben basieren
auf einer Beurteilung des Niveaus und der Art
der Fähigkeiten, die erforderlich sind, um einen
Status als Mensch aufrechtzuerhalten, und selbst wenn die
Idee des minimalen menschlichen Wohlbefindens
nicht in Form von Grundbedürfnissen zum Funktionieren ausgedrückt wird,
bleibt sie dennoch
zielorientiert  Schwellenkonto des Wohlbefindens
Menschen ist ein minimal würdevolles
Leben, ausgedrückt in dieser
ausreichenden Gesundheit, geschuldet  h Fähigkeit für alle und
Maßnahmen und Institutionen müssen
ausgerichtet werden, um dieses Ziel zu erreichen, wann immer
Menschen unter diese Schwelle fallen, ist eine
humanitäre Schönheit erforderlich. Es ist
wichtig, darauf hinzuweisen, dass der
Unterschied zwischen Menschlichkeit und
Gerechtigkeit nicht darin besteht, dass die Pflicht der Menschlichkeit
schwächer ist  ist eine schwächere moralische Anforderung,
humanitäre
Pflichten bleiben hinter Gerechtigkeitspflichten zurück, nicht weil sie moralisch
weniger verpflichtend sind oder weil sie
nicht rechtmäßig durchgesetzt werden können, sondern am
plausibelsten, weil sie nicht dazu gedacht sind,
Ansprüche zu verfolgen, sie helfen nicht zu
definieren, was Menschen zu Recht besitzen oder
besitzen  einen Unterschied macht, ob
jemand ohne Verschulden seinen Status der
Menschlichkeit verfehlt oder
jemandem verweigert wird,
was ihm rechtmäßig zusteht. Eine
wichtige Folge für die Gesundheit ist, dass
eine Pflicht zur Menschlichkeit unabhängig von
der Herkunft oder Ursache der
Gesundheitsbeeinträchtigung des Antragstellers ist  Leiden
ist seine Begründung, wie Barry es nennt,
um Not zu lindern, egal was
Es ist
in diesem Sinne nicht verursacht, wenn die Katastrophe gesundheitliche
Fähigkeiten moralisch blind gegenüber der
Ursache von Krankheiten ist und Menschen
grundlegende gesundheitliche Fähigkeiten geschuldet werden, unabhängig davon, ob ihre
Entbehrung auf Unglück, genetische
Lotterieunfälle, Naturkatastrophen zurückzuführen ist,
ob sie sie selbst verursacht haben oder
daraus resultieren  Soziales Handeln oder
institutionelles Design Ich werde argumentieren, dass
die Idee, für die Ursachen von Krankheit blind zu sein,
nicht früher erfüllt wird
, wobei ich wette, dass dies ein
willkommenes Merkmal des Fähigkeitenansatzes sein könnte,
das wir auch auf
den relationalen egalitären Ansatz
anwenden können  Was jedoch die Schwelle setzt, ist die
Menschenwürde, die meiner Meinung nach in
diesem Fall fehlgeleitet ist, und ich möchte für eine
plausiblere Version der Gleichberechtigung in
globalen Angelegenheiten als ein plausibleres
öffentliches politisches Ideal für Zwecke der
Gerechtigkeit plädieren, damit es nicht nur notwendig ist zu
machen  eine klare Unterscheidung zwischen Anspruch
auf Menschlichkeit und Anspruch auf Gerechtigkeit und
vermeiden Sie jeden Versuch, einen Anspruch
auf t zu definieren  Andererseits könnte es auch notwendig sein
, eine Priorität zwischen den beiden festzulegen, eine logische
Priorität, da die
Forderungen der ersteren durchaus davon abhängen können, ob
das Schreiben vorhanden ist oder nicht, so dass in gewisser
Weise sehr argumentiert wird, dass es eine logische
Priorität zwischen Gerechtigkeit und Menschlichkeit gibt  Wie
Barry sagt, können wir nicht vernünftig über
Pflichten der Menschheit sprechen, bis wir eine
von der Gerechtigkeit festgelegte Grundlinie haben, um darüber zu sprechen,
was ich als Angelegenheit der Menschheit mit dem
tun sollte, was mir gehört, keinen Sinn,
bis wir festgestellt haben, was
mir überhaupt gehört  Wenn also keine gerechten
Ansprüche vorhanden sind, können wir nicht
voll und ganz darauf vertrauen, dass das, was wir aus
Gründen der Menschlichkeit geben, nicht das ist, was
wir bereits aus Gründen der Gerechtigkeit schulden.
Wenn also das, was ich gebe, was mir gehört, zu
Unrecht ist, dann ist es das  nicht
meinen Platz zu geben, aber meine Pflicht, zurückzugeben,
ok, sonst würde ich einfach zurückgeben,
was dem anderen rechtmäßig gehört, unter
dem Deckmantel der humanitären Hilfe
die gesundheitliche
Leistungsfähigkeit
zu sehen und andere kleinere Probleme nicht außer
Acht zu lassen und zum zweiten Bild der globalen Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit überzugehen. Paul Kelleher und ich an verschiedenen
Stellen als kausale Beziehung bezeichnet
der globalen
Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit werde ich es in Kürze
kausaler Beziehungismus nennen, der in Thomas Pagas Arbeit am prominentesten ist.
Spannung mit Theorien zu erzeugen, die ein
verteiltes Muster haben, ist ähnlich wie das,
was ich gerade in Bezug auf
die Venkatapuram-Ansicht erwähnt habe, also ist die Behauptung,
dass diese distributiv sind  Muster geben keine
plausible moralische Orientierung, wo
Orientierung dringend benötigt wird für die
Bewertung und Reform sozialer Regeln
sowie von Subjekten und deren Verhalten
unter Personen oder unter den Empfängern,
was Empfänger in der Lage sein sollten
oder als Konsequenz haben sollten th  Sie sind
moralisch blind in Bezug auf die
Ursprünge von Krankheiten, wo die gesundheitlichen
Ungleichheiten nur zufällig bestanden oder verursacht
wurden, ist eine Unterscheidung
von großer moralischer Bedeutung, die diese
Theorien laut Paga nicht
würdigen, also die innovativsten und
gleichzeitig am meisten  Das umstrittene Element
von Polkas 3 der globalen Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit
verschiebt den Ort der Gerechtigkeit nach rechts,
also sprachen wir jetzt über das dritte Element,
die Sichtweise der Gerechtigkeit von einem
Verteilungsmuster auf eine institutionelle Behandlung oder darüber,
was die implizite Haltung von
Institutionen von einem passiven
Gerechtigkeitskonzept protokolliert  ein aktives Konzept von
Gerechtigkeit als Förderung einer gerechten Verteilung
bis hin zu Gerechtigkeit als gerechte Behandlung von Menschen
lädt er uns ein, uns auf die Täter zu konzentrieren und
über Ungerechtigkeit als etwas nachzudenken
, das den Empfängern von Krankheit zugefügt wird oder nicht,
und dies ermöglicht ihm, eine
scharfe Trennlinie zu ziehen  zwischen den sozialen Ursachen
von Krankheiten, die
laut Programm Fragen der Gerechtigkeit sind, und der
Natürliche Ursachen kranker Gesundheit, die
keine Fragen der Gerechtigkeit sind Beachten Sie natürlich,
dass nicht alle Theorien, die mit dem
Verteilungsmuster arbeiten,
gleichgültig gegenüber den Ursachen kranker Gesundheit sind
Verteilung sollte
die Folgen der Entscheidungen der Menschen widerspiegeln und
sollte nicht die Faktoren widerspiegeln, die
unverschuldet zu ihrer schlechten Gesundheit beitragen
Diese Sichtweise behandelt sowohl die Auswirkungen
natürlicher als auch sozialer Ursachen als
problematisch unter
dem Gesichtspunkt der Gerechtigkeit, da
beide gegeben sind  außerhalb der Kontrolle des Individuums liegen,
im Gegensatz dazu hebt es freie und
uneingeschränkte individuelle Entscheidungen hervor und
lässt zu, dass sich ihre Auswirkungen in der
Gesamtverteilung von Gütern widerspiegeln,
sodass nicht alle Verteilungsmuster
gegenüber diesen Ursprüngen blind sein müssen, sondern
sie werden die bündeln  relevante Ursprünge
Ihrer Gesundheit diejenigen, die für die Gerechtigkeit relevant sind,
auf ganz andere
Weise  Die logischerweise terraeum-Sicht nimmt
die sozialen und natürlichen Ursprünge als
Probleme der Gerechtigkeit und eine Art der
persönlichen Ursprünge oder der persönlichen
Wahlursprünge sind keine Probleme der Gerechtigkeit
sind Angelegenheiten der
Gerechtigkeit, während solche natürlicherweise
keine Angelegenheiten der Gerechtigkeit sind, also ist es
wichtig, wo wir die Kluft ziehen und
welche Kategorie zu welcher Kiste gehört, also
zurück zur Polka-Zentralthese, die er vertritt
, die nach einem ziemlich bekannten
Zitat die Stärke unserer moralischen Gründe ist
einen bestimmten medizinischen Zustand zu verhindern oder zu mildern
, hängt nicht nur von
Verteilungsfaktoren ab, sondern
auch von relationalen Faktoren, dh davon,
wie wir mit den medizinischen
Bedingungen, unter denen sie leiden, in
Beziehung stehen  ist keine Entweder-Oder-Frage,
denn Polka-Distributionen spielen eine Rolle
m  mündlich, aber es spielt auch eine Rolle, ob und
wie die Entbehrungen mit der Gesundheit
in Zusammenhang stehen
Zusätzlich zu dieser kausalen Rolle
betont Reporte die Bedeutung der impliziten
Haltung sozialer Institutionen. Er
unterscheidet zwischen sechs Möglichkeiten, wie
Institutionen den Gesundheitszustand von Menschen beeinflussen
können, und sie entsprechen der
Stärke unserer moralischen Gründe,
sie zu mildern.
Diese Kategorien werden nun als
Skala dargestellt  von negativer zu positiver
Verantwortung und es ist in
seinem Fall nicht klar, wie wir die Grenze ziehen sollen oder
ob wir die Grenze
zwischen Ungerechtigkeit und jenen Verderbtheiten ziehen sollten
, die keine Sache der Gerechtigkeit sind,
also ist die Sicht auf Gerechtigkeit wahrscheinlich
schon klar  die Dinge, die wir
mit dem
Maßstab der Gerechtigkeit bewerten sollten  Die Taschenfälle
sind ziemlich komplexe Angelegenheiten, sie sind Teil
eines Verteilungsmusters, sie sind Teil einer
institutionellen Behandlung, und einige Leute
berichten, dass sie kategorisch die Grenze ziehen
zwischen medizinischen Bedingungen, mit denen wir
ursächlich verbunden sind, und diesen
Gerechtigkeitsproblemen, mit denen wir
nichts zu tun haben  Fragen von moralischem
Interesse anderer Art werden häufiger, jedoch
in einigen seiner anderen
Arbeiten als graduelle Fälle
größerer oder geringerer Ungerechtigkeit dargestellt
Einige Ursachen haben ihren Ursprung in Ereignissen, die
unabhängig von der Gesellschaft und ihren
Institutionen sind, während andere Ursachen
in sozialem Handeln entstehen. Diese
Unterscheidung ist abstrakt sinnvoll,
wenn wir das aktive Konzept der Gerechtigkeit anwenden,
denn damit etwas
ungerecht ist, müssen bestimmte Akteure die
Verantwortung für die Ungerechtigkeit tragen oder teilen  dieses
Judy Kondom dieser Seite rein natürlich
yada Conda wie rein genetisch ca  Die Verwendung
von Krankheiten kann nicht gerecht
oder ungerecht sein in dem Sinne, dass sie keine
Methoden der Gerechtigkeit in dem Sinne sind, dass
es keinen institutionellen Standpunkt gibt,
von dem aus diejenigen, die die Last der
Krankheit tragen, sie ungerecht behandeln werden. Es gibt
jedoch zwei Komplikationen, die beide
sind  explizit per Podcast
manchmal nur in einer Fußnote
gewürdigt, die sein Bild von globaler Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit
differenzierter wiedergeben, als es
die gängige Lesart dieser
kausalen Sichtweise vermuten lässt, zum einen
die Art und Weise, wie natürliche Ungleichheiten
in ihren Ursprüngen mit sozialen
Ungleichheiten verstrickt sind, zum anderen  Ich denke,
wichtiger für die moralische Theoriebildung, auch wenn
rein natürliche Verderbtheiten nicht
der Gerechtigkeit entsprechen, ist die Art und Weise, wie die Gesellschaft organisiert ist
und ihre Institutionen mit den
Auswirkungen natürlicher Gesundheitsdefizite umgehen
, eine Frage der Gerechtigkeit, also werde ich das
nur schnell durchgehen  Ich denke,
es ist bereits in Taschenarbeiten vorhanden und
wird uns helfen, zum nächsten
Bild überzugehen  Da die
ersten natürlichen Krankheitsursachen
selten unabhängig von sozialen
Ungleichheiten sind, stellt ein Großteil unserer fortschrittlichsten
biomedizinischen Forschung fest, dass viele
körperliche und geistige Krankheiten
scheinbar biologischen Ursprungs
tief in sozialen Ungleichheiten verwurzelt sind. Der Ansatz der sozialen
Determinanten von Gesundheit hat
Beweise für diese Behauptung gesammelt
unterschiedlichste gesundheitliche entbehrungen
von der koronaren herzkrankheit
über psychische erkrankungen bis hin zu
schlafstörungen unsere vorgeburtliche und
frühkindliche entwicklung ist besonders
sensibel für unser soziales und familiäres
umfeld, das unser
gehirn und unseren körper grundlegend prägt neueste epigenetische
erkenntnisse wie das sogar genetische
ursachen  reagieren empfindlich auf das Umfeld,
in dem sie zum Ausdruck kommen Die
Beziehung zwischen natürlichen und sozialen
Ungleichheiten im Gesundheitsbereich ist komplex und
verflochten, und je mehr wir aus der
biomedizinischen Forschung und der
Sozialepidemiologie lernen, desto eingeschränkter wird
der Bereich dessen, was Philosophen gerne
das Reine nennen
Natürlich auftretende Krankheiten werden,
wie Poker schreibt, indem er zuerst zitiert, dass die
Unterscheidung zwischen natürlichen und sozialen
Komponenten der menschlichen Lebensqualität
nicht klar genug gezogen werden kann und
nicht signifikant genug ist, um das große moralische Gewicht zu tragen, das
wir darauf gelegt haben und das wir
für falsch und allzu simpel hielten
jeden scheinbar natürlichen medizinischen
Zustand als Krankheit zu betrachten, die vor
und unabhängig von sozialen Beziehungen
und Personen auftritt, die mit ihnen in die Gesellschaft eintreten
, was noch wichtiger ist, die Unterscheidung ist
nicht signifikant genug, um das
Gewicht der moralischen Trennung zwischen
Gerechtigkeit und Ungerechtigkeit
als zweite Komplikation zu tragen  In diesem sozialen
und natürlichen Bereich der Gesundheit tritt die zweite
rein natürliche Verursachung in einer
sozialen Institution auf,
und es ist eine Sache zu sagen, dass die
Ursprünge einer bestimmten Krankheit nicht
einfach so sein können, sondern wie sich
die Wirkung der natürlichen Ursache auswirkt
Die Gesellschaft ist oft tief
in verschiedene Formen ungerechter
institutioneller Strukturen verstrickt  Die Feststellung, wie Menschen davon betroffen sind,
dass sie die
Auswirkungen einer natürlich vorkommenden Krankheit nicht bewältigen können,
kann dennoch aufgrund bestehender Ungerechtigkeiten ungerecht sein,
da die
verheerenden Auswirkungen eines Hurrikans oder
die Tatsache, dass sich der
Krankheitsausbruch in eine Epidemie verwandelt hat, möglicherweise
noch auf eine zurückzuführen ist  Ungerechtigkeit in Faktoren, die
unter menschlicher Kontrolle stehen, wie ein fehlerhaftes
Wirtschafts- oder Gesundheitssystem, in
dem sichere Gebäude oder Impfstoffe
für die Armen unerschwinglich sind, und zitieren Sie,
was gerecht oder ungerecht ist, ist nicht, wie diese
natürlichen Güter oder Übel auftreten, sondern
wie Institutionen damit umgehen  Auswirkungen
auf die gesamten Lebensaussichten der Menschen, so dass
wahrscheinlich die Art und Weise anerkennt, wie das Soziale
und das Natürliche miteinander verflochten sind, dennoch
bleiben die sozialen Ursprünge seiner Ansicht nach ein
vorrangiger Entscheidungsträger für öffentliche Maßnahmen.
Tatsächlich scheint es, dass genau die neu
entdeckte soziale Natur oder das soziale
Merkmal dessen, was wir dachten  Eine
natürliche Ungleichheit zu sein, ist das, was
sie in den Bereich der Gerechtigkeit bringt, denke
ich  k, dass es noch etwas zu
bedenken gibt, wenn es darum geht,
unsere Gerechtigkeitskonzepte auf natürliche
Ungleichheiten auszudehnen, unabhängig davon, ob
sie in
ihrem Ursprung oder in ihrer Wirkung mit dem Sozialen verflochten sind, das
zweite Problem, das ich mit
Taschenkonto und ich sehe  Ich denke, dass
uns dies irgendwie zum nächsten Bild geführt hat.
Ich denke, dass seine Darstellung dessen, was
es für Institutionen bedeutet, Menschen gerecht zu behandeln, darin
besteht, die Auswirkungen von
sozial institutionell verursachten Krankheiten abzumildern
und natürlich auftretende Gesundheitsdefizite zuzulassen,
es zoomt auf das
Positive  oder die negativen gesundheitlichen Wirkungen
die Belastungen und der Nutzen, die
Institutionen erzeugen und dennoch
unberücksichtigt lassen, die vorbestehende oder
vorinstitutionelle Gesundheit
wird vorausgesetzt, dass sie noch vorhanden sind,
dies ist jedoch nur eine Möglichkeit
, den Inhalt dessen auszuzahlen, was eine gerechte
institutionelle Behandlung ist und  es stützt sich
auf ein bestimmtes Modellverständnis der
Unterscheidung zwischen Tun und Zulassen,
man könnte sogar sagen, dass dies der Fall ist  Dies ist eine ziemlich
enge Art zu verstehen, was
es für eine Institution bedeutet
, eine Person auf eine bestimmte Weise zu behandeln. Der
Gedanke, Menschen gerecht zu behandeln, gibt keine
abschließende Antwort darauf, welche gesundheitlichen
Ungleichheiten eine Frage der Gerechtigkeit sind, was
es bedeutet, Menschen zu behandeln  gerecht und
was eine gerechte institutionelle Behandlung
konsistent ist, ist genau eine der
grundlegenden Fragen, die
Theorien sozialer Gerechtigkeit unter den
plausiblen Antworten aufteilt  oder
für Menschen, die in einer
Gemeinschaft gleichberechtigt sind, okay, also Taschenbild
, verteilt institutionelle Auswirkungen
gemäß einer Idee von Gleichheit oder
besser
institutionelle Wirkung
gemäß einem normativen Ideal, und wir
können dies nennen  Kurz gesagt,
Gleichberechtigung ist eine Betrachtung von
der Angebotsseite der Institution,
was sie Menschen antun, wie sie
Menschen relational behandeln
es geht um
Gleichstellungsförderung, es geht nicht um die
gleichberechtigte Wirkung von Institutionen, sondern
um die gleichstellungsfördernde Wirkung von
Institutionen aus der Sicht
des Empfängers, und das bringt mich zum
dritten Bild der globalen Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit,
also nenne ich sie gut darin  diese
stufe hin zu einer relationalen legalität eine darstellung
globaler gesundheitsgerechtigkeit im
letzten teil meines referats möchte ich
eine art relationale italienische darstellung
globaler gesundheitsgerechtigkeit vorschlagen. im
kern liegt die idee der gleichberechtigung in
globalen angelegenheiten und ungerechtigkeit  der gesundheitlichen
Ungleichheiten wird in Bezug
auf dieses Ideal ausgearbeitet, wenn ich sage, was Personen geschuldet wird,
ist gleich
Ich meine nicht, in globalen Angelegenheiten zu stehen, und hier sind einige
kurze Klarstellungen. Ich meine nicht, dass
jede Person an einer globalen
Demonstration teilnehmen muss, die die interne und
externe Fähigkeit hat, sich an
globalen Angelegenheiten oder
politischen Angelegenheiten in Wirtschaftsangelegenheiten zu beteiligen, aber es geht darum,
die Gelegenheit zu haben  Wenn man sich dafür
entscheidet, einen Job zu haben, kann man einen
Beitrag zur globalen Wirtschaft oder
zur sozialen und kulturellen Reproduktionssphäre
leisten, öffentliche politische Angelegenheiten oder
kulturelle Angelegenheiten, man kann sich dagegen entscheiden, muss aber möglicherweise
einige der Verteilungsfolgen tragen, die
dies sind  Es geht nicht darum, ein
globales institutionelles und kulturelles Umfeld zu ermöglichen, sondern zu behindern. Dahinter
steht keine
Annahme einer aktiven globalen Bürgerschaft
, sondern eine Möglichkeit zur
Teilnahme, und die globale soziale Basis
einer solchen Gleichberechtigung drückt die
Idee der gleichen Sorge seitens
globaler Politiken und Institutionen aus  die
Lebensaussichten aller so was sind diese
fünf oder zumindest vier Elemente von t  Die
normative Struktur, die ich mir hier vorstelle,
ist zunächst die Rolle der Gesundheit, wie ich
bereits in der Einleitung gesagt habe,
und nicht den Wert der
Gleichheit zwischen Personen in einer bestimmten
Verteilung von Gesundheit oder gesundheitsbezogenen
Gütern zu verorten, sondern darin den Wert der Gleichheit zu verorten
was gemacht wird, was es bedeutet, sich
als Mitglieder der Weltgemeinschaft sichtbar gleich zu stellen,
die Verteilung
von Gesundheit und anderen Gütern ist
konstitutiv für dieses Ideal, und die
inhaltliche Anforderung, was wir einander schulden,
ergibt sich aus der sorgfältigen
Prüfung dessen, was  Das Endideal selbst
hat zur Folge, dass Gesundheit in dieser Hinsicht nichts
Besonderes ist, sondern ein sehr wichtiges und
grundlegendes
konstitutives Element unserer
Gleichberechtigung in der Gesellschaft oder im globalen
Geschehen ist. In diesem Fall ist es nicht die
Verteilung von Gesundheit an sich, sondern unsere
Beziehungen unsere Fähigkeit  es kommt moralisch darauf an, gleichberechtigt zu sein,
welche
gesundheitsbezogenen Verteilungen
unter dem Gesichtspunkt der Gleichberechtigung
relevant sind  ng ist das, was wir hier versuchen
, eine Art Liste zu erstellen, okay, also der
zweite Punkt ergibt sich daraus, wie wir über
die Ursprünge von Krankheit denken, wenn
wir diese Beziehung wie einen Latarian-Modus annehmen, anstatt uns darauf zu
konzentrieren und es moralisch zu
versuchen  zwischen den
natürlichen gesellschaftlichen und selbstverschuldeten
Ursachen von Krankheit zu unterscheiden
Diese Sichtweise befasst sich damit, wie
Institutionen mit den Auswirkungen
verschiedener Quellen von Krankheit und
dem allgemeinen Ansehen einer Person in der Gesellschaft umgehen. Sie
erarbeitet eine Antwort darauf, was es
für Institutionen bedeutet, Personen als solche zu behandeln
Mit diesem gleichen Stellenwert und den
Implikationen für die Behandlung von gesundheitlichen
Beeinträchtigungen aus mehreren Quellen wird
diese Ansicht tatsächlich, wie ich sagte
, blind gegenüber den Ursprüngen der Krankheit sein,
aber nur bis zu dieser bestimmten
Schwelle des gleichen Stellenwerts, ein
autonomer Akteur in der globalen Gesellschaft zu sein
Das dritte Element, die Sicht auf globale
Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit Ich muss betonen, dass
hier in der Sicht der Gerechtigkeit eine
ziemlich starke Abweichung von ihr besteht  Apulien, wir
bewegen uns von diesem institutionellen Einfluss
und der Priorität sozialer Ursprünge, wir
hin zu einer institutionellen Ermöglichung der
Gleichberechtigung in globalen Angelegenheiten, und
dies wird entscheidend sein, weil es
uns ermöglichen wird, Überlegungen zur
Gerechtigkeit auf etwas Natürliches auszudehnen  gesundheitliche
Ungleichheiten sowie Recht, so
dass die Beziehungsperson wie ein Latarianer
rein natürliche Gesundheitsversorgung ernster nehmen kann,
was zählt, ist
wie natürlich, nicht wie natürliche
Ungleichheiten auftreten oder mit welcher Art von
biologischer Beeinträchtigung Menschen geboren
werden, ob eine Beeinträchtigung zu einer
Behinderung wird oder  hängt nicht von den externen Ressourcen einer Person ab
und, was noch wichtiger ist,
wie diese biologischen Beeinträchtigungen
mit der physischen und sozialen
Umgebung interagieren  Erweiterung auf
internationale Determinanten von er  Obwohl
laut der Marmot Commission on
the Social Determinants of Health, wo
systematische Unterschiede in der Gesundheit
durch vernünftiges Handeln vermeidbar sind, sie
ganz einfach unfair sind, bezeichnen wir dies als
gesundheitszynische Gerechtigkeit, die
diese Ungleichheiten korrigiert, die enormen und korrigierbaren
Unterschiede in der Gesundheit innerhalb und zwischen
Ländern ist auch eine Frage der sozialen
Gerechtigkeit Marmot fügt hinzu, dass die unnötigen
Krankheiten und Leiden der
Benachteiligten in armen
Ländern ein Ergebnis der Art und Weise sind, wie
wir unsere Angelegenheiten in der Gesellschaft organisieren
unfair oder ungerecht sind, wenn sie
durch alternative
soziale Organisationen vernünftigerweise vermeidbar sind, zeichnet dieses Verständnis
von Vermeidungsfähigkeit als sozial
institutionell behebbare gesundheitliche
Ungleichheit ein ganz anderes
Bild von gesundheitlicher Ungerechtigkeit. Wie also wird
diese Website zu einer besonderen globalen
Website der Gerechtigkeit?
über globale gesundheitliche Ungleichheit  und
globaler Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit, wenn wir den
Wert der Gleichheit in globalen Angelegenheiten gleichberechtigt ins Verhältnis setzen
, insofern
globale Regeln und internationale
Praktiken für die Entbehrungen der Gesundheitsversorgung von Bedeutung sind,
was die Regeln
geformt hat, was diese Regeln und Institutionen geformt haben
und wie sie sich auf das Leben der Menschen auswirken und
Gesundheitsaussicht ist ein moralisches Anliegen und
das relevante Thema der moralischen Bewertung
Diese moralische Bewertung ist eine relationale,
egalitäre, wenn sie die
Bedingungen und Auswirkungen globaler Arrangements untersucht,
wobei der Schwerpunkt darauf liegt, ob diese
institutionelle Behandlung
Ausdruck gleicher Besorgnis ist und ob sie sich auf sie
auswirkt  Die Verteilung von Gesundheit unterstützt
oder untergräbt unsere Gleichberechtigung.
Eine prominente Studie, die 2014 von der
Lancet University of Oslo durchgeführt wurde und in Auftrag
gegeben wurde, hat unsere Aufmerksamkeit auf die
globale und
politische Natur der Gesundheit
gelenkt
nationalen Regierung und auch außerhalb der
gesundheitssektor ende zitat wie die welt
organisiert ist welche gesellschaftlichen und politischen
normen in global governance und
transnationalen interaktionen vorherrschen und
wer sie mitbestimmen kann sich systematisch
auf gesundheitliche gerechtigkeit auswirken die studie untersucht
sieben zentrale global governance-bereiche mit
erheblichen folgen für die gesundheit und
kommt zu dem schluss, dass sie diese betreffen
acht gesundheitliche Ungleichheiten systematisch übertreiben und
Gesundheitslasten zugunsten der ärmsten
und am stärksten gefährdeten Gruppen der
Welt verlagern Die komplexen Pfade, durch die
die Normenpolitik und -praktiken der
globalen Governance die Gesundheitsergebnisse
in der gesamten
Weltbevölkerung bestimmen, werden in dieser Studie als
globale politische Determinanten bezeichnet
Gesundheit umfasst Faktoren
wie das globale System der
Lebensmittelproduktion und -märkte, Lebensmittelmärkte, geistiges
Eigentum, ausländische
Direktinvestitionen, finanzielle Governance und
Sparpolitik, Pollock-Politik, illegale
Migration, Regime und bewaffnete Konflikte, und
die Untersuchung durch Analyse  Diese komplexen
Pfade der globalen politischen
Determinanten von Gesundheit bieten einen
signifikanten Einblick, wie jeder von
ihnen systematisch
gesundheitliche Ungleichheiten beeinflusst
Gegenstand der moralischen Bewertung
ist die Art und Weise, wie diese globalen Regeln und
Praktiken den gleichen Respekt für Personen ausdrücken oder nicht
und gesundheitliche Ungleichheiten erzeugen.
Wenn die Gesundheitsergebnisse
stark davon bestimmt werden, wie wir
unsere globalen Angelegenheiten organisieren, besteht die normative
Herausforderung darin, wie wir uns eine faire
Reorganisation dieser Unternehmen vorstellen können  der globalen
Bedingungen der globalen Zusammenarbeit Okay,
nun zum vierten Element, den Gründen,
wie wir unsere Pflicht zur globalen Gesundheit begründen können.
Der Kern dieser Idee ist gleichrangig
sichtbar diese globale Zusammenarbeit
, und natürlich ist das Problem,
dass viele Menschen sogar diese
Beziehungen haben  Aguila Tyrianer, die
mit der Idee von relationa an Bord sind  Als
Literar und Gesundheitsverständnis
im häuslichen Kontext
bin ich skeptisch, ob diese Idee
auf den globalen Bereich ausgeweitet werden kann, und teilweise
rührt die Skepsis von der Beobachtung
mangelnder Solidarität, fehlender Ideen globaler
Gleichheit oder globaler Verteilungsgleichheit
und im Grunde ihres Mangels an Akzeptanz her  jede
Art von Fuß in der globalen öffentlichen
Arena und vor allem die Idee der relationalen
Gleichheit, die am prominentesten von
Elizabeth Anderson, Samuel Schaeffler und
anderen entwickelt wurde, und sie wurde im
Kontext demokratischer Gesellschaften entwickelt, so dass es
schwer vorstellbar ist, wie sie einen
normativen Fuß haben könnte  erstens im globalen
Bereich mit diesen sehr reichen Verpflichtungen
der Solidarität, und das andere Problem besteht darin,
dass es möglich sein könnte, zu argumentieren, dass
denjenigen, die zu diesen
globalen kooperativen Angelegenheiten beitragen, gleiches Ansehen oder gleiche Behandlung geschuldet ist und sich
möglicherweise auf Kinder als potenzielle zukünftige
Beitragszahler erstreckt  sowie für ältere Menschen
, die früher Beiträge geleistet haben, aber was ist mit  Wie können wir
denjenigen, die zu krank sind, um arm zu sein, oder denen es an
den entsprechenden Fähigkeiten und Fertigkeiten mangelt, um
zu diesen kooperativen Angelegenheiten beizutragen,
die Idee begründen, dass ihnen Gerechtigkeit
und nicht Wohltätigkeit oder nicht humanitäre
Sorge geschuldet ist, also zeichne ich hier
in diesem letzten Abschnitt  auf einer Idee dessen,
was ich
beitragsbasierte Reziprozität nenne und die ich
in meiner Arbeit über Arbeit und globale Gerechtigkeit entwickelt habe, ist
die Abkehr von beitragsbasierter
Reziprozität genau die Idee, dass die
Gleichstellung von Personen nicht
an ihren tatsächlichen Beitrag zum Sozialprodukt geknüpft ist
Die Frage ist,
ob wer die Personen sind, denen
die gleiche Sorge geschuldet wird, wer die
Personen sind, denen
sie zusteht, hat dies nichts mit der Idee zu tun
oder dass Personen die Fähigkeit
haben, zum gesellschaftlichen Produkt beizutragen, sondern
diese Idee die moralisch
willkürliche Verteilung anerkennt  von natürlichen
Fähigkeiten, Talenten,
Veranlagungen zu Krankheiten und anderen,
außerdem werden sie erkannt, und ich denke, das
ist das Wichtigste  Der wichtige Teil der Fähigkeit der Person
, zu einem Genossenschaftssystem beizutragen,
hängt zum Teil von der Gestaltung
des Genossenschaftsrahmens und den Regeln ab
, die die Produktion und
Verteilung sozialer
Kodizes regeln  der gesamten Lebensperspektive
und der Ort der Gerechtigkeit ist die
institutionelle Strukturierung dieser
Perspektive. Die Bedingungen, unter denen soziale
Güter produziert werden, und die Art und Weise, wie der
Produktionsprozess den Talenten und
Fähigkeiten des Einzelnen einen Wert verleiht, müssen
durch einen Maßstab der Gleichheit gerechtfertigt werden,
damit Gerechtigkeit ist  nicht nur denen geschuldet, die
zu globalen Angelegenheiten beitragen können, sondern
auch denen, die ausgegrenzt oder an
den Rand gedrängt wurden, weil ihre
Talente, Fähigkeiten, Lebensweisen oder ihr
Wertesystem abgewertet oder
in einem bestimmten Design
eines Genossenschaftssystems wie dem bedeutungslos gemacht wurden
Weltwirtschaft okay, also wie gesagt, das sind die
vier Elemente, die versuchen zu motivieren  Wir haben unseren
Wandel hin zu einer relationalen Gleichheit zu einem
Verständnis globaler Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit gemacht
und abschließend, obwohl es noch ein langer
Weg ist, bevor wir konkrete
politische Vorschläge aus
Gründen der relationalen Gleichheit machen können,
sind einige Überlegungen bereits klar, wie wir
unsere Gesundheit gestalten und reformieren  damit zusammenhängende
globale Angelegenheiten
gehen weit über den globalen Gesundheitssektor hinaus
und müssen eine
Folgenabschätzung für globale Gesundheitsgerechtigkeit mit
globaler relationaler Gleichheit als
normativem Kern umfassen. Zuerst müssen die wichtigsten globalen
politischen Determinanten von Gesundheit
stattdessen eine Anforderung der gleichen
Betroffenheit
für alle beinhalten, die darauf hindeutet  eine Vermutung der
Gleichheit in ihren Verteilungseffekten
auf die Gesundheit, so dass dies das erste ist,
obwohl eine positive prinzipielle Lösung
einige theoretische Kontroversen beinhaltet,
aber die Ungleichheitsbeschränkung
angegeben ist, bietet sie den Grund,
gegen die derzeitige Anordnung Einwände zu erheben,
die zu gesundheitlicher Deprivation führen und ein
Accessor, der die Krankheit bekämpft  Belastung bei  Das
untere Ende der globalen Ungleichheit, die zweite
relationale Gleichheit, hat wichtige
Konsequenzen für rein natürliche Gesundheitsschäden,
genetische Krankheiten,
Naturkatastrophen usw. Sie bietet keine normative Grundlage,
um alle globalen Gesundheitsschäden zu kompensieren oder zu neutralisieren.
Sie erfordert jedoch, dass der Weg
globaler Institutionen  Umgang mit den
Auswirkungen oder Milderung der Auswirkungen
natürlicher Krankheiten wird von der Idee bestimmt
, Menschen als Gleichberechtigte zu behandeln, einschließlich jeder
Person mit den Fähigkeiten, die es
ihnen ermöglichen, als Gleichberechtigte in der
globalen Gemeinschaft zu funktionieren
Globale institutionelle Vereinbarungen,
die die Notlage von Millionen
von Menschen mit schweren, aber vermeidbaren
Krankheiten nicht ansprechen und sie an den Rand der
menschlichen Existenz stellen, anstatt
ihnen zu ermöglichen, gleichberechtigte Mitglieder der globalen
Gemeinschaft zu sein. Danke